[Music]
what Avatar showed an audience was a
world that they couldn't imagine brought
to life
in front of their eyes come I knew that
it was special I knew that it had
changed my life it was more than a movie
Pandora lives inside of all of us
you don't actually understand if it's
going to have an impact you'd you know
prepared for any impact you're just
prepared to tell a truthful story that's
what I like about Jim he just tries to
tell the most truthful honest story that
he can he should see your faces the
detail that he put into this world to
this culture and how much it resonated
with everybody just the complexity of
what he accomplished such a different
world that they've never seen in a movie
they found an affinity with something
that talked to them someone standing up
against bullies and trying to find their
way
it was just really beautiful to see that
Avatar speaks to people like that and
that they're represented on the world
stage there was something in it for
everyone
or for all of us to nurture and to
protect the place that's our home I can
understand people not wanting to leave
that world it was such a magical one
Pandora needs to come back to life again
thank you